hello this is Doug Walker and this is
the Angry Video Game Nerd movie casting
call here in Chicago we got people set
up here I'm here my brothers here
Mike Mashhad CEO channel awesome is here
and let me tell you there was a stadium
filled with people that wanted to
audition we that they've chosen it down
to 31 people that are coming here today
so a lot of people were disappointed
that they had to sit in a stadium many
of them weren't even trying out they
were just forced to sit in the stadium
and that was very sad but a lot of fun
was that noise not true but a lot fun
was had by us seeing people suffer I
heard say being a white and he's just
like you know being an african-american
being the white devil I have no place to
tell you what to do in a situation so
some of these are interesting like you
know the Cowardly Lion from The Wizard
of Oz you know or Dorothy absolute
favorite Hamlet he put Hamlet in the
hair I am I'm so curious if someone's
actually gonna do the big to be or not
to be speech cuz just would they even
hire him with James Rolfe hire someone
who did Hamlet so I think you put that
in there as a joke but I'm really
curious does eBay what tries that what
over would you say over nothing is over
until we decided it was it over when the
Germans bombed Pearl Harbor
hello the going gets tough the tough get
go let's go come on
this could be the greatest night of our
lives
this is Rob doing that can you read my
mind sketches William Shatner you I am
looking give us holding hands with a
gunnery sergeant Harper your senior
drill instructor from now on speak only
when spoken to first and last words on
your filthy sewers will be surged you
maggots understand that the prisoners
been doing the most my logs out here is
not actually auditioning there is now
racial bigotry here I don't know about
all right you guys I just make you see
that I want you to be nothing like okay
so we've had maybe 15 to 20 people
audition right now and just the ones
that really stood out just for any other
reason just or strangeness or just being
interesting what we did the ending of
The Day the Earth Stood Still the big
speech in this really thick Chicago
accent which is really uh an interesting
take on it was that to have fun there's
no concern of ours how you run your own
plan
pursue your present course and face
obliteration it was like a Chicago cop
of the galaxy coming down saying you
know clean up your act you know James
was telling me said I just put Pamela in
there just like three people do Hamlet
one of the guys did it and he had to get
tears in his eyes he actually formed
tears in the audition so it was it was
really good like I was feeling really
bad to die
one guy did Ferris Bueller's Day Off as
Christopher Lee one of the worst
performances of my career how could I
possibly be expected to handle school on
a day like this that's an interesting
choice again what I just saw which was
really bizarre was this guy comes in he
chooses from the female monologues
interesting he chooses scary movie and
he does the whole thing as a Spanish
maid
no idea why it was such an odd choice
and he also sung a song about puking so
I was pretty funny and then finally at
the end he's like do you want me to do a
real monologue I'm like if you could was
mine you know I mean he was funny and he
was good and everything so I definitely
some interesting people turning out here
so mr. Rolf you got this fall-like
monologue from Raiders of the Lost Ark
which is one of the greatest movies ever
but then summarized in just one sentence
pirate nothing is over nothing just
don't turn it off it wasn't my ward and
I do what I had to do to win but so many
were less with we had another one come
in I was doing gob he's doing the big
Independence Day like the President's
speech the being influential speech but
he was doing it like a DJ he was doing
like good morning Vietnam like he was
Robin Williams I find it very
interesting the different
interpretations that people do I think
they just really want to make a big
impact and stand out so that you
remember them because a lot of times
they'll do this really big goofy
monologue and then they'll go into there
like a normal one there there's another
one that was really really good this
woman she did a monologue as data you
should ever look good but then she
started doing in different accents which
was really smart cuz that showed what
else she could do and she start going to
these different characters while doing
this model it's a shoulder rain
and auditory senses contribute to your
hunting skills and natural defenses
mcdale is quite the central for your
aerobic talents those spot the complex
levels of beat maybe you display to
beret so stuff like that is really smart
it's actually pretty clever for how long
creatives on these actors can get okay
now now I'll ask you one question I'm
not gonna lie this is really going to
increase your chances of getting a role
who do you like better than the
Strausser craig or angry video game now
keep in mind that james rolfe is gonna
be looking at the footage but i'll be
making sure he gets the best shoes
wisely
you